welcome back before we proceed further
and and get a little bit better
understanding of why
maybe some of these investors were so
keen on investing in mortgage-backed
securities essentially loaning this
money to all of these people who are
buying these ever-appreciating houses i
think we need a few more tools in our
tool belt so i'm going to introduce you
to the concept of the yield curve you
might have heard this before you might
have heard
people on cnbc talk about it and
hopefully after about the next 5 or 10
minutes you will know a lot about the
yield curve
so when most people talk about the yield
curve they're talking about the treasury
yield curve what what is what what does
that mean what is even a treasury so
these treasury securities whether
they're t bills treasury bills treasury
notes or treasury bonds so you know
they're all start with a treasury so
there's t bills
t notes
and t bonds
all these are are these are
these are loans to the federal
government and these are about these are
considered risk-free because if you lend
to the federal government
and they're running short of cash all
they have to do is increase taxes on us
the people and they can pay back your
debt so in dollar denominated terms the
treasury bills notes and bonds are about
as safe as you can get in terms of
lending your money to to anyone so when
most people talk about the yield curve
they're talking about the risk-free
yield curve and they're talking about
the and they're talking about the curve
for treasuries so first a little bit of
a little bit of definitions what is the
difference between treasury bills
treasury notes and treasury bonds
they're pretty much all loans to the
government but their loans for different
amounts of time so if i loan if i give a
loan to the government for a thousand
dollars for any say i give a loan for
six months that will be a treasury bill
so i will give the government a thousand
dollars the government will give me a
treasury bill and that treasury bill
from the government is essentially just
an iou saying that i'm going to give you
your money back in six months with
interest
similarly if it's three months it's a
three month treasury bill treasury notes
are loans that that are from one year to
ten years so on this graph that we're
going to make using the actual the
actual yield curve rates
from zero to one year and actually
there's no zero year
treasury bill it's actually the shortest
one is one month
this would be something like here on our
graph
so from one month to one year these are
t bills
t
bills and this is just
definitional
then from one year to ten year these are
notes
actually the one year i believe the one
year itself is a note so just a i think
so
up to one year is a bill although i
might be wrong or that correct me if i'm
wrong that's just a definitional thing
from one to ten year these are called
notes
then when you go beyond 10 years these
are called
treasury bonds
these are just definitional things to to
worry about
so with that out of the way let's talk
about what the yield curve is
so when i i'll just give you a simple
thought experiment if i'm lending
money to someone for a month
versus lending money to that person for
a year
in which situation am i probably taking
on more risk
well sure if i'm lending someone for a
month i know i'm gonna
only so much can happen in that month so
i would expect to be paid less interest
not just obviously in dollar terms but
even on a you know
adjusted for time i would expect less
interest for that month
so when when i talk and this is actually
an important point to make when i say
that i'm charging six percent interest
for that month
that doesn't mean that after a month the
person is going to pay me six percent on
my money it means that if i were to give
that money to somebody for a month then
they were to pay it back and then i were
to give that money to say that same
person or another person for a month and
i would keep doing that for a year then
in aggregate i would get six percent so
that six percent no matter what
duration we talk about whether one month
one year five years fifteen years when
we talk about the interest rate that's
the rate that on average we would get
for a year it's the annualized interest
rate
so going back to my question if i lend
someone money even the government for a
month there's usually less risk in that
because only so much can happen in a
month versus in a year in a year there
might be more inflation the dollar might
collapse i might be passing on a better
investment i might need the cash in a
year's time while i have a lot of
confidence that i don't need the cash in
a month's time so in general you expect
less interest when you loan money for a
shorter period of time than a longer
period of time and so let's draw the
yield curve and see if this holds true
so i actually went to the treasury
website
so that's tres.gov
and this is the yield curve so they say
on march 14th so this is the most recent
number and i'm going to plot this they
say if you lend
money to the government for one month
you'll get 1.2 percent on that money and
and remember if it's a thousand dollars
it's not like i'm going to get 1.2
percent on that thousand dollars just
after a month if i kept doing it for a
year this is an annualized number i'll
get one point two percent and so for
three months well for three months i get
a little bit less
and then for six months i get more and
then it does seem that the overall trend
is that i expect more and more money as
i lend money to the government for
larger and larger periods of time and
this is a little interesting anomaly
that the that you get
a little bit more interest for one month
than three months and and we'll do a
more advanced presentation later as to
why
you might get lower yields for
longer duration investments that's
called an inverted yield curve
but let's just plot this and just see
what it looks like
so you saw where i got my data so they
say for one month i'd get 1.2 percent so
this is one month would be right about
here
three months i get about the same thing
for six months i get 1.32 maybe that's
like here
one
year i get 1.37
maybe it's here
five years let's see five years i get
2.37 so that's maybe like here
10 years
and these aren't all of the durations
i'm just just for simplicity not going
to do all of them for 10 years 3.44 so
maybe that's
here
three four four 20 years i get 4.3
like that
and then for 30 years i get 4.35
so the current yield curve looks
something like this
and so you now hopefully you at least
understand what the yield curve is all
it is is you know using a simple graph
someone can look at that graph and say
well in general
what type of rates am i getting for
lending government to at a risk-free
on a risk-free basis or as risk-free as
anything we can expect what type of
rates am i getting when i lend to the
government for different periods of time
and that's what the yield curve tells us
and in general it's upwardly sloping
because as i said when you lend money
for a longer period of time you're
you're kind of taking on more risk
there's a lot more
that you feel that could happen you
might need that cash you might you might
you know there might be inflation the
dollar might devalue there's a lot of
things that could happen
so the next question is well what
what determines this yield curve
well when the fed
not the fed sorry when the treasury the
government when the government needs to
borrow money what it does is say well
hey everyone we need to borrow a billion
dollars from you because we can't
control our spending and they say we're
gonna borrow a billion dollars in one
month notes so they're gonna this is one
month notes they're gonna borrow billion
dollars and they have an auction
and the world investors from everywhere
they go in they say well this is you
know this is a safe place to put my cash
for a month and depending on the demand
that determines the rate so if there are
a lot of people if there are a lot of
people who want to buy those one month
treasuries the rate might be a little
bit lower
right
does that make sense to you think about
it if a lot of people want to buy it
there's a lot of demand relative to the
supply so the government has to pay a
lower interest rate on it
similarly if for whatever reason people
don't want to keep their money in the
dollar they think you know the u.s might
default on their debt one day and not
that many people want to invest in the
treasury then that auction the the
government is going to have to pay a
higher interest rate to people
for them to loan money to it so maybe
then the auction ends up up here
and similarly the government does
auctions for all of the different
durations and duration i just mean you
know the time period that you're getting
the loan for so do it for one month
three months six months one year two
year three year et cetera
once the government has done that
auction
then
it though those treasuries so you know
you give the money to the government
they give you an iou called a t bill
then you could trade it with other
people and that's going to determine the
rate in the short term so the government
does the auction but then after the
auction say you know and a lot of people
had demand
but then a lot of people get freaked out
and the the public markets when you try
to sell that treasury will then expect a
higher yield i know that might be a
little complicated now and i and i
always start to jumble things when i run
out of time but hopefully at this point
you have a sense of what the yield curve
is you have a sense of what treasury
bills treasury notes and treasury bonds
are and and you have some intuition on
why the yield curve has the shape see
you in the next video